[Music]
here in this video we will discuss
something that arose when we watch the
eternals we saw them as another
superpowered team of 10 individuals each
having a unique power and powered by
cosmic energy
but we already had a team of
superpowered heroes in the avengers so
the question is out of these two teams
which is the more powerful one thing the
eternals have above the avengers is
biological immortality but then again
they are synthetic beings and they can
die out from damage so here in this
video we will pitch 10 of these eternals
versus 10 of the avengers from infinity
war and end game the best of the
avengers versus the best of the eternals
so can the avengers defeat the eternals
one by one let's get to it
firstly we have icarus and his opponent
is none other than thor with storm
breaker and maybe mjolnir by design from
the celestials icarus was an eternal
possessing superhuman strength
durability speed agility stamina
reflexes and healing he was regarded as
one of the most powerful of the eternals
thor on the other hand as we know it is
the most powerful avenger aside from
captain marvel and wanda maximov but he
alongside stormbreaker was able to
pierce through the infinity gauntlet
being fired by thanos
and alongside mjolnir thor would
suddenly win given that thor could also
withstand to a degree the power stone so
thor wins this round against icarus
then next we have druik and on the
opposite side is vision with a mind
stone so aside from superhuman strength
and durability druik has the powerful
ability to read and control minds with
his cosmic energy but his power would be
rendered useless when facing vision who
has in his possession the mind stone an
infinity stone that can do the same and
more so in this battle another eternal
falls in the hands of an avenger
next we have the illusionist sprite and
he will face up against doctor strange
well sprite is the grand diva
storyteller of the community of
genetically engineered beings called
eternals spread aside from being a bit
more powerful than an average human has
the powers of illusion casting
duplication casting presence concealment
and shape shifting but all these parts
that doctor strange can also do as well
to a degree but then again strange has
fought thanos and resisted for quite a
while and even with that firing attacks
at him through the infinity stones and
also strange has the genius intellect
and the ability to wield the time stone
so here again strange wins for the
avengers
so in this next battle we will feature a
girl on girl fight the superfast makari
will go toe-to-toe against captain
marvel although makari is quite a
speedster even faster than quicksilver
from hf ultron she can run at hypersonic
speeds of over 10 000 miles per hour but
even though she is this fast captain
marvel can traverse through space and
fly at similar speeds and even faster
than light to travel to other planets in
the universe even without faster than
light speeds ftl captain marvel's near
invulnerability to damage will certainly
give her the win over the speedster
so we already have four wins for the
avengers and none for the eternals so
next is the battle goddess thena and she
will go on head to head against the
super soldier captain america steve
rogers the moral compass and the leader
of the avengers is a master's battle
tactician and quite adept in many
martial arts added to his superhuman
strength speed and durability but even
with this enhancement tina has way more
more strength more battle tactics honed
on for millions of years and the power
to project weapons made of cosmic energy
so athena wins this round the first for
the eternals
now we have the brute strength eternal
who is gilgamesh and he will go up
against the brute strength of the
avengers the hulk so how do we judge
this gilgamesh and eternal is known to
be the strongest of them all like
physically strongest capable of
projecting gold and cosmic energy
enhance exoskeletons to shield his arms
and fists and also enhancing his
strength and durability in combat
the hulk on the other hand is a being of
gamma radiation that manifests when
bruce banner gives into his anger and
the angrier he becomes the more powerful
he is
well he has only been defeated by thor
and thanos so with both being extra
powerful we will give this a wash a tie
and no one goes to the second round
now the leader of the eternals ajak will
face off against the master assassin
black widow ajak was the original prime
eternal as well as the wise and
spiritual leader of the community of
genetically engineered italians who came
to earth ajak aside from having
superhuman strength and durability also
has a genius level intellect is a master
tactician an expert combatant and has
healing powers
black widow is at the peak of human
fighting skills and levels and even
though she is an assassin with
impressive skills she will fall down
before ajak in this battle so the second
one for the eternals
on the eighth spot we get the inventive
fastest versus the genius playboy
philanthropist iron man
so this is the most interesting round
both are high level geniuses will
fastest with cosmic energy and iron man
with his ai plus nanotech and both can
manipulate matter and invent powerful
weapons to take on one another although
fastest is slow he uses his cosmic
energy power manipulation to cover that
disadvantage iron man however is faster
and can fly around and with melee fights
he will most likely win but then again
the cosmic energy and instant inventions
of fastest will counteract that so here
again we have a tie and no one will go
to the second round
then now we come to cersei the master
mata manipulator and she will fight the
nexus being wanda maximov the scarlet
witch
by design from the celestial cersei is
an eternal possessing superhuman
strength durability speed agility
stamina reflexes and healing but these
powers aren't as high as the others with
her specialization being matter
transformation then on the other hand we
have won the maximum she has the powers
beyond reckoning telekinesis chaos
energy manipulation mass mental
manipulation reality bending reality
manipulation and the power to destroy an
infinity stone the mine stone and even
overpower thanos
so this isn't really a match is it wanna
takes this win for the avengers
and now lastly we have the bollywood
kingo who is a straight shooter and he
will exchange shots against the one who
never misses hawkeye kingo is an
extremely skilled and formidable
hand-to-hand combatant with thousands of
years of training and combat experience
kingo is able to utilize this energy
projection abilities with lethal
efficiency and can shoot beams from his
hands like
deshome hawkeye on the other hand is a
master marksman and a skilled fighter
and he has taken quite a number of
chitauri by himself so so he is quite
the fighter but since he depends on his
arrows and none of them can pierce
through eternal's body armor
he is certainly doomed for if he faces
gingo one on one
so let's go to the second round
ah let's not include the ones that ended
in a time shall we which is gilgamesh
the hulk fastest and iron man so on the
second round we have the eternals who
won the fight versus the avengers that
won
we have tina ajak and kingo going up
against vision doctor strange captain
marvel thor and the scarlet witch
here we see tina who will now go up
against captain marvel and thor in short
she loses to them either combined or
even in a one-on-one fight
ajac will face off against doctor
strange and vision
so again we have a two on one who will
both be able to beat her even if it's a
one-on-one battle and then we see kingo
fighting the scarlet witch obviously
wonder traps can go in a bollywood hex
and that's it so conclusion the avengers
win beating the eternals with five
surviving members against zero
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video anyway with that we come to the
end of it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash the bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam